about 10 minutes ago how I didn't know
what to say yes I know um I don't know
mom he's my best friend yeah he's great
yeah I think I am um I have to go I will
listen Jim
you have no idea how long I wanted to do
that me too
I think we're just drunk no are you
drunk no Jim
you're really gonna marry him
okay
dunder-mifflin oh hey oh my god hi
hi sorry I forgot Kevin's extension
it's a fantasy football thing Wow and I
was just gonna go through the system
because I didn't think you'd be there
why are you still there I had to work
late
Jan's making me keep a log of everything
Michael does all day Wow didn't you did
send me a copy that okay yeah totally so
so do you I'm sorry go ahead
I know I um everything's pretty much the
same here
oh good a little different what time is
it there what time is it here we're in
the same time zone
oh yeah right do you think we were I
don't know felt far yeah I think I am
gonna take that job and Scranton it's
not that bad so they offer you a job
there I think you should take it okay
yeah maybe well I could yeah I'm I'm
happy he said that I mean I don't think
he's into me or anything but I'm kind of
into him hi I'm Jim how's it doing
little joke there about how we could
never met I know I don't care
awesome good to be back the place looks
really good it's really good for you
you too where do I stand with Pam um no
idea I mean we're friends always have
been friends um that is where we stand
hey where you at Filippelli I'm at the
grocery store buying a corkscrew to give
myself a lobotomy what's wrong you
didn't have a good first day oh my god
hey you wanted me to Cooper's in an hour
I need a drink yeah sure sounds good
hey hey you know what time give you a
call right back yeah okay thanks
Hey Hey I thought you had already left
uh no I just had other stuff I had to do
good what's up oh nothing I just feel
bad I feel like things were a little
weird today or something what do you
mean I just think I should tell you that
I sort of started seeing someone oh
that's totally cool you can do whatever
you want oh okay oh good we're friends
we'll always be friends
right good have you back yeah gonna be
back I feel like I've been kind of cold
to Karen and there's no real reason for
it I mean it's not like she's ever done
anything to me so I think I probably
shouldn't be cold to her hey Karen
um sorry about that meeting today that
was really crazy Yeah right
I'm so glad you said that that does I
don't know how those meetings usually go
I'm usually like that does anyone ever
stand Daniel I think one of her cats did
once she came in with scratches all over
her face right um I really liked your
karaoke idea oh cool yeah that could
really be fine you guys do a raffle yeah
we do a raffle talk about nope I still
haven't found an apartment yet I'm
living in a hotel yesterday I saw for
rent sign down the street from Jim and
he said he didn't think it'd be such a
good idea he said it would be like we
were living together in different houses
two blocks away hey you okay yeah
you sure yeah yes I'm just in this like
stupid fight with Karen oh you want to
talk about it really
who did this to you where is he what no
it's that stopping
it's on here yeah yeah
Thanks
you don't need to stay here I know
it's you're PMSing pretty bad up Hey
do you still have feelings for her
yes
I haven't heard anything but I'd bet Jim
got the job I mean why wouldn't he
he's totally qualified and smart
everyone loves him and if he never comes
back again that's okay we're friends and
I'm sure we'll stay friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know I shot him down and then he did
this name to me and but you know what
it's okay I'm totally fine Jim I called
off my wedding because of you and now
we're not even friends and things are
just like weird between us and that
sucks and I miss you you were my best
friend before you went to Stanford I
really miss you I shouldn't have been
with Roy there are a lot of reasons to
call off my wedding but the truth is I
didn't care about any of those reasons
until I met you but you know what it's
okay
I am totally fine everything is gonna be
totally sorry um are you free for dinner
tonight
yes all right then it's a date
I'm sorry what was the question
you